okay
thank you thank you everybody welcome to
this this
license and subcommittee meeting which
is
to look at an objection from the
environmental health officer to a
temporary event notice
issued for archway from maynard strand
in
old trafford i'll start the meeting by
doing some
introductions um mr ryder the committee
this afternoon is made up of three
people
that's myself councillor anne duffield
and i'm the chair of this committee
my two colleagues councillor brotherton
and councillor butt
make up the decision-making committee
this afternoon
also in the room today we have our um
have a licensing manager joanne boyle
who will present the case
have legal services and lisa grimshaw
and um the representative is angela
[ __ ]
from environmental health and then also
in the background
is our governance officer who's keeping
one eye on the
um on the meeting so this meeting is
being live streamed
should that live stream stop at any
point it can't be really started
um hopefully you won't get thrown out of
that but if you can we'll get you back
in fingers crossed that meeting um
we may adjourn for a short time if we
think it's necessary if anybody else
has leaves the meeting or internet drops
out but we do have all the written
statements in front of us and will award
due weight
to those as we feel appropriate please
mute
your microphone to minimize background
noise
the meeting will follow the order of
hearing as we normally do in these
matters
everybody will have an opportunity to
contribute ask questions
and make closing statements should you
need to interject at any point
in the proceedings please use the chat
facility within zoom to notify
myself and then wait until i invite you
to speak
any such interjections should be kept to
a minimum
and it would be helpful if for the
purposes of the minutes you can just
introduce yourself when you speak
so natalie owen is also here from our
democratic services who will
make minutes of the meeting we run all
our meetings in the same way
the licensing manager joanne boyle will
outline the case in front of us this
afternoon
my committee colleagues may have
questions or clarifications for her at
that
stage we'll then hear um
we'll then hear from yourself mr ryder
then you can lay out the obviously the
the application in front of you today
and then there'll be an opportunity
again for my colleagues and myself to
ask questions of you
and then angela pollock from
environmental health will
lay out the objection and again we may
have questions and clarifications
at that stage and they'll then be an
opportunity
for all parties to make closing remarks
the meeting will then end and we as a
committee will then will
go off into another room and we'll
deliberate and then come back and give
you our determination of our decision
this afternoon
so if you just wait here we'll go and
then we'll come back again
into this meeting does anybody have any
questions regarding this
process before we begin
[Music]
no i'm all good thank you so just to
make it clear
that this afternoon we're here to
look at any evidence in line with the
licensing objectives and there are four
licensing objectives
the prevention of crime and disorder
public safety
the prevention of public nuisance and
the prevention of children
from harm so
i'm going to start off by asking jerome
boyle to outline
the application thank you very much
thanks chair
members of the subcommittee um the
licensing act 2003 provides a system of
permitted temporary activities
under which licensable activities can be
carried out
without the need for a premises license
these
activities can take place under the
authority of a temporary event notice
given by the premises user to the
licensing authority
only the police or environmental health
may intervene to prevent an event
going ahead if they believe that to
proceed would undermine the licensing
objectives
on the 15th of july 2020 the licensing
authority received a temporary event
notice from mr oliver ryder for an area
known as archway one
pomona strand at old trafford the air is
an open piece of land
underneath a railway arch which um we
believe is privately owned it's not
owned by
trafford council so the subcommittee may
wish to ascertain from mr ryder if he
has contacted the landowner about the
land as
he would be required to seek separate
permission to use it for the event
the tempo event notice given by mr idios
for a proposed event on the 30th of
august 2020 which will involve live
music
and the sale of alcohol between 2 p.m
and 11 p.m
the event is described as an occasional
food and music showcase
members may wish to seek further
clarification on the nature and content
of the event
this matter has been brought before the
subcommittee because the authority has
received an objection to the notice
from the council's environmental health
team on the grounds that to allow the
event would undermine the licensing
objectives and you have already outlined
what those objectives are
the subcommittee is requested to
consider the submissions of the premises
user mr ryder
and the objector environmental health
and decide either
not to accept the objection
accept the objection in which case it
must issue a counter notice
under section 105 of the licensing act
which would mean that the event
the event is not authorized that's what
uh the the um my submission for for
now unless you have any questions for me
at this stage
i don't counsel counselor brotherton if
you've got any questions at this stage
no no okay um
so mr ryder there's an opportunity now
for you to
talk us through your application and um
the risk assessments and all the work
that you that you've done
in line with the licensing objectives
that are in front of us today
yes of course thank you everyone for the
introductions it's a pleasure to meet
you all like i said earlier thank you
for taking the time today
to sit down and talk through this
application to give you a bit of a
background on kind of my event event
experience and this i really think
plays a big part in why i feel
comfortable and confident in
running an event as this it's only for
200 capacity
i've been working in events for the last
six years although it's not related to
this it's kind of built up a portfolio
and understand how
the running of events for up to ten
thousand capacity uh
twenty thousand capacity a weekend and
then for a festival which is eighty
thousand
i i understand fully because i run the
market in promotions for
a company that sees them numbers i've
been running these type of events
under my own brand which is called
animal crossing which is what this event
is for for the last two years
and the narrative of the brand is that
we find these spaces um
every single month so this is the first
time we found one in trafford but every
single month we've put in these
temporary
temporary events notices we've built up
a real reference
with the manchester city council with
the manchester police they trust us in
what we do
for every event um and we from one quite
similar to this under a railway arch
which capacitated
for the 499 for the full tens and there
was no issues no noise complaints
all the development risk assessments
i've done so really this this
size and scale of event is really small
to what we're used to doing
but the most important thing obviously
pre-copied we was hitting them numbers
comfortably but because of the covered
risk assessments that's that's the most
important thing for this event in
ensuring that they run safely and the
weekend just gone on saturday we ran the
first
social distance party in the uk
successfully the council came down the
police came down
it was no issues whatsoever and they
were super happy
with how with with the plans that we had
in place and just to run you through how
that worked in terms of the kobe risk
assessment
so prior to the event you could only
purchase tickets
in groups of in your social bubbles
worth of four five and six
once you arrived at the venue we asked
everyone to facilitate and carry
and carry out and i've got this for
every single person that arrived this is
the track and trace so every single
person that arrived we had to assign the
the track and trace
information once they was arrived in
they was offered a free mask
sorry the temperatures were taken we've
got a temperature gauge taking the
temperatures
and they would offer they were offered i
can say a free mask free of charge
hand sanitizer was available and then a
member of our staff
would um would take them upstairs it was
on a rooftop and open our rooftop
and they were this is the floor plan
i've sent over the floor plan for this
event as well but this is the floor plan
so the the entire area was designated
into
into everyone's own areas and they were
segmented by pet barriers
so everyone had their own square for
their social bubbles of four
fives and sixes which had a table and
their own areas and if he was on the
left-hand side
there was an option to cue for the
left-hand bar where there was spacings
and markings on the floor
and on the right-hand side again that
was managed on the right-hand side and
then we had a
food vendor on site there and like i
said the council and the police came
there was no issues they were super
happy with how how everything works
there's
sia security members on the top floor on
the toilets floor to make sure there was
no lighter in
and then on the bottom floor and to kind
of address
some of the concerns that was raised for
this particular term that i just wanted
to kind of cover the social
distance you measures and the covered
risk assessment because for me
personally
that is that that's the most important
thing at the minute obviously with
everything that's going on in the world
the actual running of events
like i've been doing that for six years
it's it's really small scale it's just
making sure
the people in attendance are safe and
secure
so and to address some of the issues
that was mentioned for this relevant
um for this relevant tent in terms of
the dispersal and causing of nuisance
um just to make you aware before any of
our events each individual that has
purchased a ticket and all tickets are
done prior to the event there's no one
who can turn up on the door and buy
tickets
and just because again that just
prevents any any form of nuisance
everyone is sent an essential info and
on that information it always contains
um taxi numbers um relevant ways to get
homes obviously it's by the metro link
so all these guiding informations of how
people can
arrive and ingress and egress securely
is always part of our wider risk
assessment and making sure that people
are dispersing and entering with as
minimal noise as pos
as possible in terms of
the area like you said it's completely
open air we would control the the egress
the ingress from panorama street we
would have
um would get a pet ferris harris fencing
so there would be a direct um route in
and out of the premises um all of the
surrounding area which would be used for
the event space
that would have harris fencing up as
well so there would be no way anyone
could enter or exit
without having entered through our
direct
route of ingress and egress all of these
um because of where it is and the
location we appreciate that it's an
unusual space but
this is we do this these are the type of
spaces that are used
um all the time i can forward over um
images and videos from the previous
event that we ran which was in a similar
location
obviously there wasn't any social
distancing because you didn't have the
social
distance then um but just to kind of
give you a view i'm not sure
i can forward this over but that was
under an archway
don't worry i couldn't forward that over
um so yeah
generally i just want to just and and
just
emphasize just the importance of how
professionally these events
are run like i said i work for a really
big events company
which is completely separate to what i'm
doing but that's where i've kind of
earned and
learned how to throw these events
securely and then for the past two and a
half years
i've been finding these unique locations
and we've had no complaints it's just
that this is the first time in trafford
that we found a location
and i appreciate that this is necessary
to kind of build up that layer of trust
um because you know you've never heard
of my name before and
you thought who's this guy trying to
throw an event under the under the
archery which i completely understand
and appreciate but from my perspective
it's kind of building this relationship
with you guys and you
with me earning that trust with you the
only way to do that is to kind of do a
couple of events in trafford and build
that relationship which again is just
critical
okay um just before i ask my colleagues
if they've got any questions for mr
ryder can you just address the point
that joanne boyle made earlier about who
owns the land
and your permission to use them so i i i
did um a land registry and it told me
that it was owned by the council
if that's incorrect then i need to i
need to rectify that and find the
ownership
and then obviously it won't go ahead if
if it's not if i don't have written
permission then
obviously the event can't go ahead it
was just i i saw when i did the land
registry said it was owned by mcc
um which i can forward that information
over and if they've got that incorrect
and i need to i need to address who the
ownership of
i know in manchester we're in trafford
so um it wouldn't be owned by manchester
city council if it was in trafford
do we have any clarification at all
joanna lisa about
land ownership we just know it's not our
land okay um
i believe the information i had today um
was that it was it was possibly the
manchester
ship canal and there was a lot of
discrepancy over the actual address
and some searches conducted did say that
it indicated it wasn't
council land um we would need to look
into that further i mean if if it is
council land obviously permission does
have to be sought
from the council to use it for those
purposes and i imagine it would be the
same
um be that another organization so
the onus is usually on the event
organizer to ensure they've got relevant
permissions in the first instance
yeah i mean that is the case with all my
events it was just because it said the
land registry sent
it to me and i can follow this
information over to you i paid for the
land registry
because before all of our events i seat
the owner and then i i agree a deal with
them to use their spend and take all
liability we've got public liability
insurance up to 10 million
all of these things are always covered
when i'm dealing with with the owner of
the premises the owner of the land
but because i did the land registry is
there is there a reason why you've not
got that in place before
applying for an event notification
because it was done this is the first
instance where it's told me that it was
owned by the council
by the council is there a reason why you
haven't
asked for permission to use the land
before you put the temporary event
notice in
because from my perspective this is the
first time it's it's come up that is
owned by the council
i obviously i've wrongly wrongly assumed
that
if it's owned by the council if i'm
putting a 10 in it's down to the council
to
admit that i'll reject that based on
that based on that knowledge of it being
owned by the county if that's incorrect
that's
on my on my on my shoulders and i can
rectify that
and if if everything else is agreed
safely then i can find out
if we can find out who the owner is and
i'll get i'll get a written confirmation
before the event can
take place because obviously if we can't
find that it can't happen
and just the other thing that um jerome
boyle licensing manager raised was just
was just about the nature of the event
um how would you describe the the event
in if we were in normal times are we
talking about rain
we're talking about dance events what
are we doing
what were you talking about in terms of
an event how would you describe it
in one sentence so this is not no not a
code no coded compliance plan this is
just the general ethos of the brand
yeah it's it's a mute it's about what an
event
it's a music and arts showcase so i base
myself strongly i've got
a big interest in arts and the culture
of when you arrive in amsterdam when you
arrive in berlin
when you arrive in any other european
city music is respected as an art form
because they combine the two arts
together and so during each and every
one of our events we spend a lot of
budget on working with various different
artists from across the uk from across
europe we bring these guys in
to to to to to create a bespoke and
unique
creative so for example the one in the
archway we work with a local graffiti
artist who completely
graffitied the full archway it was an um
it was an immersive experience that he
was within it
um i marched pre-covered and we was
meant to use one of the
um old car show rooms on upper brook
street um i work with a guy
from switzerland who has done um he's
got a lighting showcase and so all of
the so imagine you've got an empty car
showroom all of the the windows on the
car stroll room had these coloured films
on it
so like a coloured vinyl and then as it
would have turned day we would have
shown
it was a day into night event there was
a light that would have passed through
it and it would have projected
what that looked like a rainbow across
the dance floor
which is amazing the dance floor and the
the djs yes so it's um
it's a lot of european djs it's quite
underground music
it's not like thumping music it's quite
groovy um our age range is from like 23
to 35 it's a bit of an older audience
people who've got a lot of respect
and do a lot of digging in terms of what
music they're into it's not just a load
of young kids it's people come and they
respect what we do massively
um yeah we're really proud of what we've
been creating for the past two years
it is a dance event yes it's music and
arts
music and arts obviously that that has
been refined
to everything has been toned down
massively um but it's still just an
opportunity for people to
get out of the house right
let me just say my before i will have
some questions but i'm just going to see
whether or not
my colleagues or the council brotherton
yeah
thanks just going back to the
bubbles and the social distance saying
does that mean an individual no
individuals can
apply for tickets online you have to be
a group of four five or six
people that's correct that's correct
there's a bubble but don't they have to
be
from two households or something you
can't you can't
bring five or six people from different
households can you call yourself
a bubble so that so when when we put the
ticket and information out there
it is we say you must attend in your
social bubbles of four five and six
so there's no it's impossible for us to
gauge on that but that's like if anyone
was to arrive in a pub in four five and
six
we're doing everything we can from a
commons perspective and a ticket in
perspective to ensure that people in
their own in
individual bubbles are arriving so
there'd be no one no one can buy
individual tickets if you turn up in a
two or
three you were rejected entry
unfortunately that happened a couple of
times at the weekend
we just couldn't let them in because in
our eyes it's just not safe
i think that that's my point really that
you you personally can't tell whether
they're actually in a bubble can you
just six people who turn up
who might be six random people but you
don't you can't know that can you
because they've just
it's it's the same with with any
instance from a pub or a supermarket or
a restaurant it's
impossible to police but from our
perspective the cons that we put out
there we stress the importance
you must have been in your social bubble
of your household or your friend's
household or people that you've
interacted with previously
yeah because you could because because
these it's our entire industry that has
completely come to a halt so
i've worked so hard on this plan for
months i've honestly i've been non-stop
on the phones while initially would and
devon
and mitchell from the late night team
just checking that everything i was
doing was was up to scratch until they
okayed and approved a plan which was run
successfully on saturday
yeah okay thanks chair thank you thank
you very much
what's the so please remind me how many
people have
you expecting for an event like this
for this one because of the size of the
space it's 300 you could easily fit a
thousand people in the space that we're
asking but
it's been based on the measurements and
working out how many bubbles and squares
we could fit in there
with enough of the spacing and for
people to to be there safely
yeah and in terms of uh
the people attending you're saying that
uh there's a track and trace system
you'd have but
what's the level of authentication you
could have for that i mean
is there some kind of system where you
you have
actual names and contact details of
people so that
they could just you know just make up
some names and
so everyone who purchased it so don't
show that piece of paper again this is a
public meeting
sorry i apologize i've addressed this
thanks
i apologize so we've everyone who
purchased a ticket because obviously you
can only buy in four fives and sixes
there will only be one so there's only
50 people who could buy a ticket
but they could all buy for four five or
six from the weekend so
that wasn't enough for us in terms of
the track and trace and this is the
information that i was just about to
show to you
so there's 33 pieces of paper here with
everyone who's attended all their
information on and that was checked with
this
the original ticket holder's name so say
for example joe blogs
it was joe bloggs and then his three or
four
other people that he'd come with they
all had to write their names
their home address their mobile numbers
and their emails and we
contained all of that documentation here
prior to people that was part of the
process prior to entry as people were
queuing spaced apart
they had to fill in this documentation
before they were granted access to the
venue
okay okay thank you thank you
um mr ruddy you were just saying you're
your average age is sort of between
23 and 35 but i suspect you'll get
some people younger than that some
people older than that within within it
what are you looking at over 18 yes
so you must be over the age of 18 to
enter the premises all like
everyone is required to show their id to
one of our sia security guards upon
entry and anyone who doesn't provide
that um will be will not be permitted
into the venue
um we have a plus 21 system at the bars
whereby this clear signage and spirits
levels etc is all shown and if you don't
look over the age of 21
for the bars then you um you've got to
show your id
just just just just for consent
you're um your coding risk assessment is
is quite basic it's sort of half a page
of a
of a4 and you talk about some things on
that that
don't exist like you talk about a test
and trace down but
there's no such thing at the moment as a
test and trace that
so i think when we come on and talk to
our colleagues in environmental health
about some of the things there's just
some of that to bear in mind
when you were doing your event in
manchester on stock on saturday night
was that the perfectly run
socially distanced event what were your
challenges in running
an event of this of this nature i i was
actually i'm super proud of how saturday
it was a daytime event
how it worked and like i said we had
visits from the council and from the
police and they were satisfied with how
how we had implemented the social
distancing rules so
i'll talk you through um step by step
how things would happen
so we had a gated area outside where
there was distancing of two meter spaces
markings left on
the floor so if one group would arrive
the second would have to wait two meters
behind
a group would arrive i would greet them
first of all thank them for coming
explain how critical that this event was
in terms of allowing further events to
happen and how important the social
distancing measures were for them to
implement that for that they've been
implemented
in they have been implemented and for
them to follow them
um once they'd arrive as i said they
would be given um this document which
would mean all of the all four or four
five or six attendees would have to fill
in the information
as that at first i'd asked for the
ticket holder the person who purchased
the ticket to show me their ticket
before this happened
then i would scan their ticket they
would write the information and so it
would be passed on to their friends
um as they entered i would explain that
as they walked through through the door
they would be greeted by my colleague
who would take them upstairs
um and they would be granted to the
floor map which are presented earlier
and they would be given their designated
area
again my colleague would explain this is
your designated area you need to stick
in your bubble please do not go to any
other
any other spaces or blocks if you need
to use the bar
you are placed on say for example the
left hand side here is the queuing
system the one-way system for you to use
the bar
and then they'll be shown which was the
pathway to use the bar and how they
would go back around to their social
bubble their square
and this process will be repeated and
repeated and repeated until we hit
capacity like i said there was a couple
of people who tried to turn up in twos
and threes they were unfortunately not
granted access to the premises
um on the top floor we had um
two sia security guards just to police
everything um
the cueing at the bar system so we had
two like i said two bars even though it
was a 200 capacity event so
the queueing for the bar was never too
frequent
um i guess the issues were as it got a
little bit
later into the night you know people had
a couple of drinks you know
the security guard just had to keep
reminding people that they needed to
return to their squares stay for example
when they went to the toilet it was
a couple of people lightering but they
were quickly escorted back into their
relevant bubbles
and their relevant squares um but yeah
aside from that
the the feedback and the response um
from everyone that i attended
um it was it was just super positive
people were just
happy to respect the message they were
just happy to be able to go out to it to
an event of some form whatsoever
and yeah is that the first event that
you've run
during lockdown yes that's been the
first one that's been granted
and have you run any other events in
trafford before
no this is this is this is the first one
right you've not run events over in
trafford
park at all no this this is the fir this
is the first venue that i found the
first premises
okay okay we may
um we may have some third questions can
i just ask you
about your before i come on to um angela
[ __ ] from environmental health can i
just ask you about your interaction with
the police
and the licensing team in trafford the
the police licensing team in trafford
and any conversations you've had with
them i've spoken to
claire i think it is
is it claire give me two seconds let me
just check
yeah claire cunningham i believe
is it claire i don't know i spoke i've
spoken to one female from trafford
police
um who was just asking a lot of
questions about how the event was going
to be run
um and then i just mentioned the fact
that i'd been running these events for
two years
so that i usually speak with alan
isherwood from manchester
um and then she had a conversation with
alan who who assured her that i won
these events
securely and then she rang the back just
to let me know that she'd had that
conversation and from there she's not
she's not spoken with me since
in terms of trafford i've spoken with
jade who handles the
licensing yeah
and then and then aside from that i've
just had information um
was it a guy called ian i think as well
rang me just to let me know that this
was happening
um and just taught me through a few
details okay
okay thank you we might come back to mr
ryder um
angela pollock from environmental health
is going to run us through the
information that she's submitted
as well as part of this application and
objection
thank you angela flores thank you
good afternoon everybody and as you know
i'm one of the environmental health
officers
um my role includes health and safety
and
more recently obviously providing
guidance on
corona viruses and the law
by way of background the law relating to
coronavirus restrictions
sets down a gathering organized by
business
which takes place outside can be allowed
for more than 30 people
providing that a risk assessment has
been carried out
which meets the requirements of the
health and safety legislation
and that all reasonable measures to
limit the risk
of transmission of corona virus taking
into account this risk assessment
have been taken this effectively means
that the covert 19 secure guidelines
must be met
the guidance states that those
organizing events must take additional
steps
to ensure the safety of the public is
imperative
at such gatherings that social
distancing
between different households or support
bubbles is maintained at all times
and to answer the question raised by
council brotherton
earlier at outdoor gatherings groups can
be made up of six people from different
households
um i would like to say that my objection
is based on
the information provided in the
documented risk assessment
and that perhaps at the end of the
process
and there hasn't really been an
opportunity to engage so some of these
points
you may be able to clarify at the end
but this objection
is based on the documentation that
i received last week um
so my objection to the issuing of the
temporary event notice
is based on the fact that i do not
believe the requirements have been met
in relation to covert 19 to core
guidelines
the event is for 300 people and
described as we've been told
as an occasional food and music showcase
i've only really now come to understand
that the event
includes dancing
and i understand there'll be a selection
of djs
the most significant point that i would
like to highlight
is that the social distancing has been
set
at a metre apart rather than two meters
the reduction of distance in from two
meters to one meter
means the importance of other control
measures
being correctly identified and
implemented
is absolutely vital it should only be
the case
that social distancing is reduced to one
meter from two meters
where it is not possible to be two
meters
as apart event is outdoors i'd suggest
it would be possible
to apply the two meter distance in
layout changes could be made or if not
possible
numbers should be reduced to achieve a
two meter separation
in addition mitigating factors must be
in place
where only one meter distance is
occurring
in lag in line with covid 19 secure
guidance
information available in the covid risk
assessment
doesn't appear to demonstrate compliance
with all elements of the covid19 secure
guidance
any risk assessment process should work
on the basis of a hierarchy of control
measures
starting with the highest possible level
of control
first in my opinion
the following points demonstrate that
the hierarchy is not being followed
and that not all of the mitigating
factors set down in the covert 19 secure
guidelines
are being demonstrated so as mentioned
the decision to have only one meter
distance between such a large
volume of people and in particular
setting the tables only one metre apart
where social distancing guidelines
cannot be followed in full
the business should consider whether the
activity is necessary
the next stage of mitigation in the
hierarchy of control
which is outlined as being essential in
all available guidance
is the need for increased surface
cleaning sanitizing and hand washing
this includes all touch points cleaning
regimes for
toilets are particularly essential
the risk assessment has not identified
any cleaning or sunny tiny
sanitizing measures and no reference at
all has been made to hand washing
many outdoor events are supplied with
portaloos which have hand sanitizing and
hand sanitizer only and do not have
running water
the use of portaloos at large events
should be discouraged
i'm not aware at the moment at this
moment in time
what sort of toilet provision there is
um next is noted that masks will be
provided to guests
however as they'll be food and drink it
would seem unlikely
that guests are going to be wearing
masks very much
in addition face coverings should not be
a replacement for social distancing
measures
frequent removal of masks can also
increase
contamination risks and this makes the
point about hand washing that i raised
earlier even more essential
high volume pinch points such as entry
should be controlled by means of
staggered entry times
and potentially also the provision of a
number of different entrances
if this is possible it's also normal to
implement one-way systems around the
venue
and provide signage so that customers
are clear on the procedures they should
be following
the risk assessment should also consider
the ability to manage audience behavior
particularly when alcohol is being
consumed
activities or features that are likely
to encourage
audience behaviors which increase curvy
19 transmission risk
such as crowding clustering and physical
contact
outside household groups or support
bubbles
should be avoided and prevented
so it's important to understand how the
dancing
is going to be controlled and that is
not really
something that's covered in the risk
assessment
um plus my understanding is that the
tables
are only one meter apart
in connection with the previous point
controls for excess alcohol consumption
would also be required
and i'd need more information about the
controls
within the risk assessment in relation
to covered measures
i haven't been provided with a procedure
for emergencies and evacuation
and finally i noted before that you
spoke about
queuing at bars um
contacts should be minimized at bars
and areas like food vendors there should
be contactless ordering and
table service which can be achieved by
the use of apps
all these measures are set down in the
guidance
if you can't avoid bar service there
must be procedures to prevent customers
from remaining at bars
and screening should be considered
between
staff and guests
that's my end of my representation
thank you thank you um councillor
brotherton
any questions at this stage
yes could i just ask angela with regard
to um
people serving food and drink are there
special requirements needed to stop
cross contamination because of that
seem to remember i went to a vet they
weren't even allowed to take tickets off
people because of the
the possibility of pieces of paper
transmission
the virus so either i don't know it's in
the uh
corvid risk assessment but are there any
particular
requirements to limit by either having
different sorts of cops on
a different method of operation um yes
there are
this is where it's important that um
the service of food and drink is made as
contactless as possible
and so avoiding cues in relation to your
specific question
um they should make disposable
items you know disposable plates
disposable cups
as far as possible and should be minimal
returning of items that have to be
washed
there should also be procedures for any
items
that have to be washed the guidance even
talks about
um having disposable condiments sachets
and things like this rather than things
that people reuse
again um if people were moving around
between tables which you would hope is
not going to happen
this is where cleaning comes in
and this is why and any touch point
is it essential that it's cleaned and
disinfected
thanks angela thank you thank you
counselor
yes thank you uh just one on uh
on the this toilet side of things like
the i'll take it these
uh would be porter portable portable
toilets that you'll be using
yes that's correct and what's the level
of
hygiene for these i'm not i'm not used
one for many times but uh
what what what have you got in in terms
of being people being able to make
themselves corey compliant in those
so we we use a company called dr lou and
obviously they
would have been completely sanitized
washed down prior to our event they
would be
they would be brand new in them um
as and as angela pointed out there is
hand sanitizer
there's a hunt on time sanitizer
available in each particular unit
there's a queuing in a one-way system in
in and out of the toilets and this
the section would be managed by an sia
security guard to ensure that people are
have got the correct space in they have
got the using the correct ingress and
the egress points
for the toileted area um there is no
there will
be no running water but we will we hope
we do provide water behind the bar
um it's obviously not got a water point
um but we do we do provide water behind
the bar for people to
to wash their hands with if if requested
um
that will be paid for would it yeah
all right and uh
what would be the situation when the
hand sanitizer was
depleted you know how often would they
be looking at that
we will as i mentioned for the event on
saturday there was hand sanitizer
available at every single contact point
contact payload it was only contactless
payment as well just to just wanted to
clarify that apologies if that wasn't in
the risk assessment it was just everyone
was just paying contactless
there was sometimes hand sanitizing all
bars all toilets and we had
we've got we have got an abundance of it
we wouldn't run out of it
so we could just keep topping it up and
it's available everywhere
okay thank you um
just um coming back to some of the
evangelists points mr ryder just
in regards to why you're not doing table
service and why you're operating a
queuing system is there a particular
reason why you've
chosen that strategy over one that would
potentially make your event more coded
secure
is something that we could possibly look
at i think just
going off the event and having actually
run it successfully on saturday there
was there was
no queueing it was just literally it was
a fast service
because it's not like we're serving
cocktails or anything that requires a
lengthy time it's just a quick
process it's a quick exercise your event
on
200 so it's another hundred more
um that's quite interesting because
online it says that your
event on saturday had a smaller capacity
than that
just a marketing marketing marketing
strategy
for 150. it was just a marketing
strategy
there was more than that yeah yeah it
was licensed for 200 it was just a
marketing strategy and andrew to go to
go back to your points in regards to the
one meter there's enough space down
there to make that two meters that's not
not an issue whatsoever
that's not in the risk assessment that's
in front of us this afternoon
where we will determine the application
the assessment is talking about one
meter in the risk assessment that you've
given to
us not a problem just to clarify
people are actually in a fenced area for
their bubbles
it's not like they're stood next to each
other or on a table
next to each other they're actually in
in a boxed off
fenced area for each bubble
can i um can i just ask you another
question mr ryder what's your knowledge
what's your knowledge of current covered
infection rates in trafford
what what research have you done to
understand
the current position in trafford and and
where
infection rates are at i haven't done
any
anything specifically for traffic for
trafford right
so you have no idea what what
you're trying to risk assess against in
terms of
a specific local authority that you're
looking to run an event in
i've just been focusing on ensuring that
the event that i'm running will be as
cobia secure
as possible and understanding where my
clientele come from
which is manchester so trafford council
tweeted
last night that while overall cases in
traffic
remain low the numbers are creeping up
especially
amongst 18 to 25 year olds so
you're not aware of you know you've not
done any work or any research around
the types of things that you're trying
to mitigate i haven't specifically in
trafford i've just been work focusing on
creating an event that is safe and
secure right but without knowing
that data it's very difficult i suppose
to know
about what it is that you're trying to
mitigate against in terms of
the biggest stuff within the risk
assessment but then also
what's actually going on in in the area
and some of the things our director of
public health is currently
dealing with an increase in rates of
people between 18 and 25.
i do have a strong knowledge on our
audience and where they travel from
and where they come from and there isn't
it's mainly manchester rather than
trafford
area okay
so i i understand what who who comes to
our events and how to make that safe for
them
which is what the input which is what
what which is the the importance of this
is 10 is making sure everyone who
attends is safe
and is secure and it's not going to
catch colby or prevent it and if and if
anything does happen we have the
tracking and trace
systems in place to to work out how and
where that come from
our um the the council's environmental
health officer this afternoon has done
i think in in quite reasonable terms um
stated that the the risk assessment in
front of us this afternoon is inadequate
for the
for the event she's pointed out a number
what might have been suitable for
another authority
isn't necessarily obviously doesn't
doesn't meet some of the standards that
we might
expect in in traffic so i just wondered
whether or not you had any other
points that you wanted to raise um back
in
in in regards to some of the points that
angela had raised
around the risk assessment around
our expansion around surface cleaning
around no one in running water in
louvres around one meter for distance in
around staggered entry times around
controls for excess alcohol around the
fact that there's no emergency
procedures
um and i was just wondering whether or
not you wanted to have another
opportunity to comment comment back on
that to us yeah of course
all bar surface areas are cleaned
regularly
and that's a part of the instructions
and the briefings to the to the bar
staff members
um the ingress times are staggered and
people do arrive
people are given the last entry time and
uh generally speaking we get say like
10 arriving two hours before that 20 the
extra hour before that
um forty percent the extra hour after
that and all of this
we have we have a great understanding
from understanding what our audience are
like and when they arrive all this is
provided in the essential info
um which all customers are um sent prior
to
prior to the event um in terms of the
running water
it's a solution i can try i can try and
find a solution for it i'm all about
finding ways that we can make this work
um i just have to speak with with my
internal team who handle all the comms
and making sure that we can we can
provide a solution for that i'm sure
there'll be some barrels and a system
that we can make sure that like if we
can put a pump in you know if if that is
what we need to do
we can do that um and then
was there any other other points i
suppose at this moment in time there's a
little there's
also the issue about who owns the land
that you don't know who owns the land
that you want to run this event upon
again i i i assumed it was council owned
because i
paid for a land registry which told me
that that was the case
obviously the event can't go ahead if we
don't get signed from
from the person who owns the land but i
i did a land registry which told me it
was council owned
so that's that's why i win this
participant if
solidify who owns the premises then we
can get permission and if not then we
can't do the event there that should um
just one other point mr ryder we're
obviously in the middle of a
global pandemic at the moment and ninth
clubs
are not opening and as you have pointed
out earlier
very eloquently the event that you ran
in manchester at the weekend was the
first of its time i'm
just interested in your view of running
these types of events
during during a pandemic when nightclubs
aren't permitted to open and the
nighttime economy
is just is just coming out of that about
what makes this event
different to um to other events that
that aren't being run at the moment
um you are the the guidelines state
you're allowed to run outdoor events
which is what we've done and we've
i it's fortunate that our brand ethos
and the narrative of what our
our events are they're always in these
unique locations
and so it's just about understanding how
we can run these in a safe and secure
secure environment just like people can
go to the pub just like people can go to
bars just like people can go to
restaurants we're providing that
that that scenario but in event
circumstances
okay i don't have any further questions
is there anything else that
um you want to add before we use
if you in a summing up and then see if
there's anything else for environmental
health is there anything you want
to say to us before we deliberate on
this application
i think you know obviously we are in a
middle of a global pandemic and ensuring
that the safety of the customers
is is the number one priority that this
is this is a plan that i've worked on
tirelessly until i've seen the rest
once i started seeing the rest of europe
approach and start doing events again
outside
i was approaching all these other
promoters across europe obviously it's
different legislation in different
countries but i was getting some form of
knowledge
from that knowledge i was then having
direct conversations with them with the
manchester council and the manchester
police about how i can run this safely
and securely
and then on saturday we have been given
the opportunity and granted the
opportunity to do it to do it
and by by all means i'm so proud of what
we did it went safely went securely
people
understood people respected it i i've
been to a couple of bars and there was
less social distance in bars than there
was on our event just because it's
classed in this event and it's got a dj
playing it shouldn't be tarnished as
this place that is not able to solidify
social distance and it is possible and
we proved it on saturday
the the scale of the event and making
sure it's safe and secure is my number
one priority
the rest of the industry needs to return
back to normality and us being able
to do these events safely and securely
as a guinea pig almost
it gives people hope and i i'm confident
in that the structures and the plans
that we've got in place that can be
implemented
to this venue is not going to be an
issue whatsoever i can address
any any issues or circumstances in
regards to the two-meter rule that's not
a problem the space is more than big
enough
we will find and comply with whatever is
necessary to us
despite the plan that we we've gotten
used on saturday it worked perfectly
if there's a few minor detailings that
need to be abide by to work with
trafford then i will be more than happy
and open to
i'm willing to do that to prove to you
guys like i said it's the first instance
that we've worked and collaborated with
the traffic council
and so it's important for these
relationship relationships to start off
properly correctly and to build that
layer of trust
it's so important it's critical and you
know obviously the big key factor is the
land land ownership as well which
again as i've stressed if we don't get
that then it can't go ahead but i just
want you guys to know that this event
will be run professionally
safely and securely because that's my
number one priority like
i i i did a personal post on on my on my
socials to just stress how important it
was
and everyone who was arriving everyone
completely understood they complied
and we i've got a really good grasp of
who our audience are and what they're
like it's not like we're dealing with a
lot of kids
we're dealing with adults who respect
and understand it and they're just
thankful and grateful that we've been
given the opportunity to allow it to
slowly allow these things to happen
again
and so yeah i'd just like everyone to
bear that in mind and hopefully
um you can see how professionally and
securely and safely that
it will be ram and thank you for your
time
andrew is there anything else that you
want to say in closing at all
yeah can i say something oh sorry dylan
just yeah come up yesterday
yeah uh there's something that was
touched on earlier by the
environmental health officer about
screening can i just
elaborate on that what that issue was
this the screening sorry the the trust
the tracking trip
the the yeah also it's the stainless
steel
or all of the bar services and they're
the the the um
the bass the bar teams have all got
sanitizers and the relevant cleaning
products to clean that frequently that
it's consistently being cleaned it's all
contactless payments
it's a one-way system for the bars it's
only a fast service bars it's not an
advanced cocktails
slushies etc it's just quick service
contactless okay thank you
i don't know if there's anything else
that you wish to say um
at all before we um before we go and
deliberate we've not you've already said
anything you hold anything else that you
wish to add at this stage
and thank you i think i just really want
to emphasize
the importance of cleaning sanitizing
and having hot having water available
for hand washing
to the guests at the event um these are
quite
basic things that are set up down
in the gardens um and
they're also sort of basic
prerequisites for hygiene that um
we need in our everyday lives um
even when we're not in in a pandemic um
so i'm really very very concerned
that these things haven't been
identified
in the risk assessment and the
guidelines
are available online and
you know it just is quite concerning i
know we can work on these things but
i do feel that they are very important
aspects um that have been overlooked
and do you have andrew do you have any
contact from mr ryder or his colleagues
before prior to the temporary event
notice going in at all
um no and also i emailed last thursday
um to try and start a bit of an exchange
and
didn't receive a response until
today unfortunately so there hasn't
really been any opportunity for us to
engage with one another
where we may have been able to sort some
of these things out
i i just want to come back on that and
say because i wanted to wait until the
event happened on saturday
because i wanted to come into this
meeting with the information i've got
from running an event successfully from
that
for them that comes from that so i do
apologize but that was my reasoning
behind it i wanted to go and have a
narrative of how things have been done
it's all well and good
having this concept in place and these
ideas of how it can be done until you've
actually lived it and experienced it
and hosted an event for someone drawing
covered a social distance and level
you're not aware so i was i was waiting
for this conversation to happen so we
could
discuss today so i'd be able to explain
how things were actually rolled out
and how they worked and how people were
safe
and secure and it was covered compliant
quite challenging to us to do that in
the middle of a committee meeting mr
ryder we'd probably expect all of those
things
to have happened before we get to
committee where we're here to determine
the information in front of us today
this is this isn't a discussion and to
some extent this is a determination of
an application
so it makes it quite difficult for us to
take sort of some of that
because we haven't got that written down
and we haven't got enough data
that's in front of us today when we
determine this application
i i know that moving forward as i said
at the very beginning of this it was my
first one so i've never had to do this
previously like i said i've been doing
these for two and a half two two and a
half years now and i've never had to do
this prior so
generally when i've when i've dealt with
anyone with who's had an issue he's been
on the phone and it's been explained
so i apologize and you know i now know
that moving forward
okay and i i i do i do appreciate that
as well
there's anything else you want
throughout mr ryder just before we close
i i that that's all of my points i just
want to i just want hope
that i've given enough information and
having actually done this on saturday
uh having a case study i feel is
important as well as well as the
experience that i've had throwing
much bigger and bigger scale events
hopefully that is enough
and information we
will um we'll go and deliberate so if
you wait they
will probably give us 15 minutes or so
we'll put break on and get brew or
whatever i'll put the kettle on
we'll come back but thank you for your
time thank you so much everyone i'll see
you shortly